[Music]
in two big news
oh it's never too big oh I'm just
kidding it's really there's a cat is a
pornstar I can't [ __ ] shove like 12
inches of knowledge that's dude that's
not obviously a deal-breaker like if a
guy's dick is too big and it's an actual
deal-breaker you guys hear that
gentlemen she gets here so yes if you
want to know if the [ __ ] dick size
matters one time I was in line in a
bathroom in a club and this girl was
asking everyone else in line like is
this too big like and we were all like
yeah she didn't [ __ ] this guy after um
this guy was Senate she was like gonna
hook up he said was like sighs it was
hue ya know my cervix lie down that's
too big yeah he's probably super proud
of it little does he know yeah she's
like I'm kind of scared and everyone in
line we're all strangers were like yeah
that's stupid
you know you're gonna get hurt
my cervix is not about it man submitted
by I stop hammer time stop my time
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Hammer pants a woman is suing her
ex-boyfriend after is abnormally long
penis stretch turban jar this is two
levels of stupid like this is stupid
wait that is stupid you can't [ __ ]
stretch your [ __ ] vagina
what the [ __ ] yeah her like John I ready
lengthwise unless she was doing kegels
and then he made it tighter and then it
stretched it back out and like undid
what she was doing if she said you tore
my vagina I'd be like I get it
right that's possible it's always there
if that was that do don't really good
smoke gets home getting soup or walk
everyday of one accord today Cosmetics
too big I'm like real sad about your
light yeah man she sue me cuz well my
dick is so big well I guess humble
bragging every day biologically I feel
like that would be convenient if you
were procreating you know now it's all
baby size for a baby to come out you're
welcome for that oh for her vagina yeah
every person who's ever had like every
woman who's had a baby would just be
like shut the [ __ ] up you don't shut the
[ __ ] up you dumb right here vagina feels
sure sure all the time saying cuz my
[ __ ] still tight yeah I'm just sayin I
can't really I can't really I didn't go
through it can't relate either I haven't
had a baby so I believe you anyway so
there's this woman she's 29 years old
she is suing because she's planning to
undergo reconstructive surgery
oh she so oh she just wanted money for
reconstructive surgery because she
didn't think her [ __ ] was tight enough
no she said well she claims that her
[ __ ] was tight before she met her ex
back in 2016 but then now it's so like
stress how you gonna win that court case
you called to the stand ex-boyfriends
are like yahoo [ __ ] tight and amantha
[ __ ] used to be two fingers now it's
three we dated it was tight yeah he's
like when you started dating miss
Lawrence was her [ __ ] tight once you
compare it to what would you compare it
to like this or like this flashlight or
this much light over here
yeah the raiment of fruits please
identify how tight miss Lawrence is I
Chyna was always more like like this one
yeah was this one I would love to be in
that courtroom I just loved to be in
that courtroom I want to be on the jury
I would bring you I'm gonna be like sir
we need some evidence takes place in
Zimbabwe oh I'm not saying it I believe
her right now thinking it I'm saying
Oh Bose you can say it
okay how do i phrase this well I guess
what they say is true the darker the
berry the bigger when the birds and the
bees and the juice in Berkeley the
sweeter that if it's if it's brown it's
big yeah that so it's hard for me to I
mean what did they what did they
conclude well they haven't concluded is
just though she's suing him for that cuz
I had a [ __ ] baby and [ __ ] went back
to normal like a [ __ ] 9-pound baby
you ain't had that magic dick y'all have
seen psycho
some big-ass big-ass baby if that
[ __ ] can't stretch and it's true
I stretch her out then the smell I feel
fine bring him to the court
like show them watch this guy's dick is
bigger than tight I see a virgin before
I guess that would be I mean if you were
like a virgin had sex with one guy right
I remember when I was in high school
like I'm pretty sure this [ __ ] was a
little bit tighter than it is now but I
feel like there's a threat there's like
a there's a limit right like there's a
ceiling to how much I couldn't even get
a tampon up there before yeah so I mean
from virgili the first and second and
maybe third guy and then to like 10th or
whatever like there's probably some
difference so that's as far as the my
[ __ ] got stretched out argument goes I
also feel like have y'all over like you
know been going at it before and like
perhaps he goes a bit too deep I should
her penis is too light you you like stop
it's just like stop
it raise your left hand if you feel pain
yeah and like you know if she wasn't if
she wasn't telling like stop let's let's
cease and desist like come on hey you
were complaining they were dating for a
while cuz they met in 2016 when who told
you that her [ __ ] was loose like the
new boyfriend was i right I see Lou you
sure wasn't ex-boyfriend you wanna go
check it out real quickly
imagine your new boyfriend says that's
you dating this girl and she says I need
to tell you something with my
ex-boyfriends penis was huge you cannot
date her without imagining every night
like do it so - think of that is like
Thor comes down from the ceiling and
it's just [ __ ] your girls like how
does he feel after that all right if
she's dating someone new have you guys
ever been through that before like the
guy that you dated before had a bigger
dick and then the next guy you're just
kind of like yeah and you can't Ally say
anything with no mind incrementally
bigger it's like an exact sketch smaller
and smaller and smaller and smaller like
it was a bar graph
it'd be like wow that's so perfect but
you saw profits every year he's way
bigger now than it was ten years
hopefully I can definitely use it it's
not loose if we go oh that looks good
Steve is probably [ __ ] you but not a
bad situation of if you're married girl
you can't take any regular dudes now
yeah
maybe literally said the other night
she's like well Steven I can only have
sex in one position it's true what yeah
because his dicks too big and you should
come to so many times like Steve on
blast I'm sorry Steve
everyone knows too much about him but my
favorite position used to be doggy style
and now Oh God it's like very hard to do
that position yeah like unless we've
been having sex like every day like
multiple times a day then it's like you
have to be stretched out over time but
if we go two days without sex it's back
to like virgin status and then after
like you know gradually get used to his
size his endowment from this and like
everything I know on are having a great
marriage like this how do I recommend
marrying for love and dicks I'm
definitely like I'm picturing like
whatever like Steve gets home he's like
Nick no you know it's like she gets home
and I'm like hey babe hey you wanna have
a meeting upstairs and he's like I'm
tired and I'm like oh man interested in
the beginning of this video that dick
size does not matter okay dick size dick
size does not matter it's how you use it
I really is if you can hit that girl -
if you could hit the spot then it's then
you're good yeah but it's just easier to
hit the spot if it's bigger because you
have more of a chance of heat I don't
agree I did not like the bigger dude
that I had I was just like those too
painful I can't enjoy it I end up
feeling like I have a rash or some [ __ ]
up yours is too much friction burns and
yeah like goes beyond where it needs to
go and maybe just like moves your
insides where I listen if you're a dude
and you're feeling insecure now because
we're talking about dick size your dick
can fit there's a [ __ ] out there for
you as long as your day is it this big
and as long as it's bigger than this no
you can use it that fat di
this much can we get at least this month
I can't what up the minimum minimum
really is about how you work it oh yeah
cuz I've had smaller guys that can
[ __ ] work it yeah well because when a
guy like when a guy just has a big dirty
dick he's like you she'll open this high
and that's it but like when a guy kind
of has like a normal or smaller dick
he's like let me strategically hit ya
the g-spot or he's like I like the girth
rather than the length like yeah yeah
yeah yeah guys I see one of those little
bird dicks real long and he's like eight
and a half inches baby I'm like half an
inch circumference like that's just but
that's like a weird chop the regular
dick in heaven but but like all he cares
about he's like we got the inches baby
we made it but we made it chopstick
chopstick or like a [ __ ] soda can a
soda can
yeah I couldn't get a soda cannon though
that should the wine is well you can
work I mean kind of song either how
about that me and that's true now I will
just do it myself
ethnicity what was the biggest ones
Mexican Mexican for her and you ever
wonder what happens on a girl's wine
night here you go no thanks apparently
we talk about dicks all day I mean for
me it's white guys but that's like you
know I've only I'm only dated white guys
nation yeah my mojo one white guy a man
the other one was half chinese and half
Dutch oh okay
I made out with the colors of the
rainbow sounds pretty high I'm not
and a dick that was all the colors of
the rainbow not affirmative action so
casually with a soft sniffle after work
[Music]
[Music]